we're going to start I just wanted a few
just a few warms of were warm words of
welcome to a room that's not as warm as
the Welcome is but basically my job and
I think the school's job is to try to
reduce the level of stupidity in our
field and that project to reduce the
level of stupidity accelerates
enormously whenever professor stiglitz
is in the room so I just want to say
again how amazingly generous he is to
return to this space and to help us to
understand better the world that we're
in and every time there are ripples that
go on and on and on and I want to
embarrass you about that but I think
there are I suppose in every epoch
certain characters who have the capacity
to envision what is happening and to
describe and in such a way that it
almost forces multiple levels of
feedback and truly professor stiglitz is
one of those people and a perfect
demonstration of that is the sort of
spectacular panel that's in this room
you do a great honor to the school
that's entirely undeserved but if you
ever feel like making the same mistake
again please do welcome back and to all
of you who are here thanks for coming
this is an intersection between an
amazing program of echo gram number
three that has just been an astonishing
set of reflections about Africa from
from the point of view of architecture
but the point of architecture also means
dance and art and literature and science
and so on but it's also the intersection
crossing over with an amazing series for
the committee for global thought so
again once again the committee of global
thought is an incredibly natural partner
to us some might argue that architects
were the first global professionals I
clicks were on the road the medieval
Masons were not at all anonymous their
signatures to be found they were
enormously arrogant their signatures
generally as you walk into any of those
buildings their signatures there they
cruised Europe continuously advising
nobility that the the other Mason who
had done it before was no good we were
very very quick to
become attached to Airlines nobody knows
airline seats like architects and
airline schedules so the pathetic
species that we are the one thing we
have almost without realizing it
developed and intelligence about is the
global environment that we find so for
to a certain extent architects are ready
for this conversation and we look very
look forward a lot to the leadership of
the committee for global thought okay
long word of welcome thanks for coming
and let me thank all of you for coming
this is the first panel of the year
sponsored by the committee of global
thought and we're having a whole series
during the year on the world in Africa
and I also want to thank mark dean of
the school of architecture and this is
as he mentioned part of their third
annual epigram conference called the
african decade so tonight we're going to
be discussing global aid in africa and
i'd like to introduce the two very
distinguished panelists we have on my
left is paul Eisenman I knew Paul very
well well he was working at the World
Bank and after he left the World Bank he
was head of the DAC Committee the
development assistant committee of the
OECD he was headed the division of
policy coordination at at that committee
and his recent work has focused on
global programs and health education
nutrition accountability and
transparency but also on a gather
architecture and now locations okay so
so different kind anyway Lewis kakaka
Kasich ND also worked with me at the
World Bank he was executive director the
World Bank
I was there now he's acting deputy
governor the bank of uganda and he was
the from two thousand six to two
thousand nine he was chief economist of
the African Development Bank when I last
visited in january and african
development bank under under his
leadership as chief economist has really
achieved a real prominence and advice in
in conceptualising development in africa
and they were all very sorry that he
left to go back to Uganda but as the
Africa is lost is Uganda's game and his
research focuses on a macroeconomic and
financial policies including
liberalization structural adjustment and
African economies the global economic
crisis what the way we're going to
structure this is the focus as a safe
tonight is on aid in africa and i'm
going to ask both of them to give a
ten-minute introductory remarks then I'm
going to ask a few questions and then
we're going to open it up to the
discussion I ask who do you want to
begin
okay how do you want to begin okay okay
okay yep all right good well thank you
very much Joe and Mark I'm really
honored to be here with you and while
talking about a number of the points
that I've learned and colleagues that
I've worked with on issues of aid
effectiveness have learned that are I
think relevant about aid to Africa and
development in Africa this I want to
cover more than there's time for us i'm
betting it going right in there first
lesson that I've certainly learned over
time is don't overestimate the
importance of aid many people including
moyo easterly sax and in fact many
donors do overestimate that influence
oil for example ii for example rightly
notes the correlation between poor
progress in a dependency but i think she
gets the causality reversed in general
except that she does have I think one
really important point too much aid for
a given country circumstance can not
only the store exchange rates but more
importantly too much aid where
governance is weak can make donors into
codependent enablers of poor policies
and of weak institutions so if it Africa
were to rise rapidly to the very very
high levels recommended by Jeff sex we'd
all have reasons to worry there is
regrettably though very little risk of
that
second on the other side don't
underestimate what aid can do to help
countries that are trying hard to help
themselves if aid is really so terrible
as oil and easterly tell us then how
about Rwanda how about Mozambique how
about Ghana how about tanzania who've
gotten high and sustained an increasing
aid levels and i should add uganda into
the gay list who are doing very well
apparently in spite of this aid and of
course there are many examples outside
of Africa of countries that have gotten
a whole lot of aid that are doing
extraordinarily well Vietnam is a
striking example there but by the dish
with a social accomplishments in spite
of governance problems another next in
reality more aid is needed for Africa
but for Asia as well but the emerging
need for belt tightening in donor
countries threatens their past promises
of increases in it and this points to
the need for more attention to
innovative and sustainable financing
such as through a Tobin tax but we need
to recognize that political leaders in
donor countries are likely to treat
these flows as fungible so that their
medium-term additionality is far from
assured there's also more attention
needed to mechanisms to reduce risks of
internal shots including through the
newly socially conscious IMF and we're
just talking before about how long would
that last but I most certainly seems to
be changing next policies are crucial we
all know that and we all know that
policies are in reality pretty highly
indigenous than they come from the
buying governance in institutional
situation but that doesn't reduce the
importance of set of setting the best
feasible policies for a given
institution and for example we've seen
many African countries that have used
fiscal and exchange rate policy to react
effectively to the ongoing global
economic crisis and Uganda is indeed one
of those and as a result of that crisis
of course ideas and good policy or
changing the mainstream has recently
moved significantly to what Joe and his
co-authors have referred to as a visible
hand now there's plenty of room for
argument on a case-by-case basis as well
as on a general basis for just how
visible that hand should be and which
countries are capable of what kinds of
manipulations with those hands next
point there should be a frank dialogue
with a lot of empathy on the part of
donors and a lot of listening I think
we've all learned the hard way that
neither externally imposed
conditionality nor high levels of budget
support for weak development programs
will lead the sustainable results rather
what I've learned anyway is that donors
should think of countries facing
problems as if they were cousins this is
if they were members of their same
family to be treated with respect and
also with frankness Joe Stiglitz his
ideas get listened to in part because
he's a brilliant and persuasive
economist but it's in part also because
cousin or maybe Uncle Joe is a good
listener who acts like a member of the
family that we were talking before this
thing about the conditionality and you
know there's different kinds of
conditionality there's the ex-ante kind
you must do this or will catch your we
won't give you a tour will cut it this
indirect conditionality that comes
through the allocation process or that
comes through saying will give you
budget support for what you have done
after the fact won't tell you what to do
will give you a budget support after the
fact in a sense they're all
conditionality but there's a very
important issue of respect and I think
that really does matter a lot next I'm
going to skip the the next point for now
save the same time they focus on
sustainable results and that is in a
nutshell the the argument underlying the
Paris declaration and accra agenda for
action that I hope most of you know
about agreement between the donors and
developing countries and civil society
about kind of rules of the game for
relations between aid donors and
developing countries getting aid and
that's why this focus on sustainable
results there's so much emphasis on
national ownership on coordination or
so-called harmonization alignment of
donor assistance behind government
programs what governments do is an awful
lot more important than what donors do
in developing countries need to seize
the opportunities that this set of
agreements in barasat craw has given
them the whole donors accountable and
some of the same countries that that I
have mentioned have also set a very good
example of holding donors accountable
and I think in this context easterly is
model of aid searchers who largely
bypass governments looking for bottom-up
approaches would be a big step backward
in terms of aid effectiveness but also
politically there are indeed lots of
capable governments in Africa l's
elsewhere that have been doing a lot and
Meredith support now I think I can't
talk and we can't talk about Africa
without talking about fragile states
unfortunately Africa has more than its
fair share and there's a very broad
consensus that ignoring them would be at
the peril of their populations of those
are their neighbors and of global
security there's an awful lot that can
be done including through NGOs in those
situations but it should always be with
the idea of contributing to longer on
capacity and institutions some have
argued that half of aid should go to
fragile states but I think this is
justified only by an econometric sleight
of hand that I will not describe what
kind of wants to ask me about it be
happy to tell you and you don't need to
be concerned to agree with moil and
easterly to be concerned about waste and
to be concerned about adding
inadvertently to state fragility so it's
it's important but it's tough and now
let me say a word about the dangers of a
disease that aid is long suffered from
which is fat ism the idea is whatever
we've done in the past that was wrong
now finally we have the answer and here
are three recent fads that particularly
affect a and
countries in Africa first one is that
most age should disperse primarily
against monitor abort term results and
in fact linking aids or results is
important but what we see in practice is
insufficient focus on the institutions
and the capacity required for
sustainability of results and the
problem is that much worse in practice
when donors in their zeal for results
and for value for money are seduced into
taking over the design and monitoring
and often the choice of what's to be
financed and that leads to the second
fad that of global sectoral initiatives
we should for example in Africa do much
more an infrastructure and we should do
more on agriculture and we should do
more on health and we should do more on
education and other sectors to indeed
where shouldn't we do more aid donors
can go to high level meeting several
times a year and promise that no good
program in that priority area will go on
fund it and often the sectoral
initiatives are accompanied by earmarked
global funds which may be dispersed on
results short-term results or not and
it's not that these initiatives don't
have some real justification one by one
they do there are important issues of
global public goods or giving a global
push to high return neglected issues the
issues rather the adding-up problem and
the related distortionary impact on the
country priorities that donors have
agreed in the Paris declaration the
acronym defer action to align themselves
behind so they said look we want to
support your priorities but then they go
and they set up all these global
programs that preempts the country
priorities and if they get too big
that's a real problem third and
finally we're now in the week following
the mdgs summit their impact has been
much debated in my view they've had a
huge even if it's hard to quantify
impact on public and political support
trade and they've helped recipient
countries as well as donors to stretch
further I think their biggest problem is
that they're often used in an
exclusionary way quite the opposite of
what they what was intended when they
were launched about 15 years ago they
were then they were first called the
deck goals then they were the
International Development Goals and they
became the millennium development goals
in two thousand for example secondary
and higher education is not included nor
is the health of males over five years
old unless from specified communicable
diseases as Adrian would who some of you
know has put it MDGs should be taken
seriously but not literally his point
applies of course to the other fads
mentioned and beyond can I have one more
minute or last point leadership is
crucial leadership can take different
forms but what's needed is commitment to
development relative to private
objectives of national leaders and the
capacity the get development programs
carried out without that aid can
certainly help build capacity for the
future but the dialogue on policies and
institutions is likely to be a dialogue
of the Deaf and I've been there but note
that effective development leadership
can take quite different forms I think
all of us in this room believes very
strongly in democracy and in human
rights but some who see democracy as a
precondition for
excess in poverty reduction and in MDGs
don't want to recognize that there are
fairly authoritarian regimes in Africa
and elsewhere that have achieved
extraordinary progress and then some
like moyo again council autocratic
governance understating both the
successes the real successes of
democracies in Africa and elsewhere and
the likelihood of choosing the wrong
autocrat I will stop there thank you
very much thank you very much
thank you our cover six areas the first
one deals with the diversity of the
African economies how the crisis has
reconfigure the raw image and capacities
of the Bretton Woods institutions how
the crisis would also affect aid over
the long term the specific policies i
think that countries have implemented in
the work of the crisis and then they're
all of the africans whenever we talk
about africa we should never look at it
as one africa i think the first speaker
has touched on all these issue we have
resource-rich countries we have resource
poor countries and we also have the
fragile states that he touched on this
means that there are large differences
between African countries in respect of
their need for aid and the modalities in
which eight should be delivered it's not
useful to discuss aid to Africa without
taking account of these differences my
main point i think is all slightly
different from the first speaker but I
in part agreeing with him that aid is
most needed in the fragile states where
the state capacities have been eroded
and in some cases have collapsed revenue
mobilization is weak and private
investments is low but this is also
where it is often most difficult to
spread aid and meet the strict criteria
and conditions imposed by eight donors
the priority for men of these fragile
economies is tribute a functioning state
which can provide
essential public services and create the
conditions for sustainable economic
recovery these countries need aid
unfortunately donor agencies often fail
to provide sufficient aged support
government budgets in the fryer steps to
support the rebuilding of the state and
public services because of fiduciary and
other concerns in this country's aid
bypasses the government budget and does
not contribute the rebuilding of this
debt to me this is being shocked cited
by aid donors because this difficult
raised the fiduciary standards without
strengthening the state capacities and
we also need to change the aid
allocation mechanisms used by the
Bretton Woods institutions to take
account of this fact when I was still at
the world at the African Development
Bank we started a study to look at ways
of changing the CPI a to include
vulnerabilities of countries in the age
allocation formula now in contrast to
the fragile countries almost 20 African
low-income and middle-income countries
have sustained strong economic growth
for over a decade some of them have
acquired the status of the frontier
markets they are on the path towards
emerging market status many of these
countries wants to reduce a dependency
because it is regarded as being macro
economically and fiscally unsustainable
and a threat to sovereignty to achieve
this they are strengthening their
domestic tax systems they are depending
their domestic bond markets and in some
cases Ghana Gabon and Singapore Kenya is
also in the pipeline and you
then they are looking to access external
commercial debt by issuing sovereign
bonds unfortunately we sometimes impose
constraints on these frontier countries
because they are post hitting countries
and constrain their access to
non-concessional resources for these
countries which seek to reduce a
dependency the mult rato institutions
should aim to channel more funds to the
private investors on commercial terms
through the private sector investment
arms although private investment has
increased in many of these countries in
the 2000s it is too much lower as a
share of GDP than in the high growth
economies of east asia moreover the
continued to growth of private
investment in africa could be threatened
by global shortages of investment funds
or greater risk aversion on the part of
private investors therefore the IAFIS
could play a useful role in providing
equity and loan finance to the private
sector in africa the IAFIS could also
channel some of this money through the
Regional Development Bank's the second
area is how the crisis has configured
the raw image and the capacities of the
Bretton Woods institutions what we had
during the crisis is less conditionality
more flexibility and a combination of
medium long-term financing and the
short-term crisis response the economic
crisis affected Africa through a
negative shock to the balance of
payments lower commodity prices reduce
the demand for the experts on tourism
lower FDI has what the African countries
required most to offset the impact of
the crisis
was balance-of-payments support to be
effective in meeting the needs of the
African countries the balance of payment
support had to be made available for
quick disbursement and to be relatively
free of conditions which could have
restricted its use or delayed plasmons
the IMF was able to set up balance of
payment finance two countries facing
temporary balance of payments
difficulties the global economic crisis
in my view has given a new lease of life
to the IMF prior to the crisis was
becoming largely irrelevant in many
parts of of the world but treats credits
the fund quicker set up a range of new
lending facilities to meet the
requirements of its members including
the African countries indeed kenya and
tanzania among the others have accessed
resources under the exact exogenous
shock facility the African Development
Bank also introduced new lending
instruments for its regional members one
of those facilities which introduced was
the emergency lending facet and we had a
lot of debate as to whether a
development bank should introduce an
emergency landing facility that provides
quickies bustle two countries some
people felt that that should be a role
for the IMF while there are these
tensions between development financial
and financing from
this was a fund mainly targeted to
central bands private sector and the
middle income countries the African
Development Bank also introduced a trade
finance line of credit which provides
short-term lines of credit for trade
finance to commercial banks this again
was another new area for the African
Development back however our biggest
challenge was designing an instrument to
respond to the requirements of the law
income countries they are far too as the
ADF of either countries these countries
needed budget support off sex shortfalls
due to falling commodity prices experts
on terms of trade our tourism true was
infrastructure financing for key
long-term development oriented
infrastructure projects and three
supporting the private sector workman
through leveraging of the idea even the
frontier countries that I talked about
earlier the likes of Botswana the likes
of Namibia even South Africa they
preferred budget support to close
infrastructure gaps as opposed to
balance of payments support for purposes
of financing of X portal or building up
of
so there is this challenge of having a
resource that meets the requirements of
of the countries now how was the crisis
effect aid over the long term in the
first half of the 2000s the
industrialized countries which are the
made major aid donors and contributors
to the IAFIS made ambitious pledges to
quit increase aid over the long term in
the context of meeting the Millennium
Development Goals however it would be
prudent to treat these pledges with a
great deal of escapes the public
finances of the major donor nations are
under enormous strain because of the
global economic crisis then we then move
on to the non-traditional donors my view
is that non-traditional donors including
China and India are likely to play a
more prominent role in the long term in
Africa than has so far been the case
China is likely to be the foremost among
all the non-traditional dollars its
financial support to Africa is likely to
increase because of the enormous
financial resources artists at its
disposal and also because it wants to
use these resources to further its own
commercial and political interests the
availability of Chinese aid and
commercial financing on a large scale
offers major benefits for Africa it
carries less overt condition rated on
aid from Western countries
the IAFIS it is often used directly to
work productive resources in Africa and
to build the infrastructure which is
needed to complement production there
are four Chinese age may prove to be
more conducive to long-term growth and
structure transformation than
traditional Western aid nevertheless
there are some valid criticisms of
Chinese a notably the lack of
transparency in some cases which could
involve African countries selling their
natural resources to cheaply to obtain 8
now the next area is what are the
specific policies that have been
implemented in the wake of the meltdown
in the financial markets and their
implications for African Development
their policy responses of African
countries to the global economic crisis
have been a true genius and having part
depended on the financial and financial
resources available to each country and
government on the continent countries
which prior to the onset of the crisis
had sustainable fiscal positions and
sufficient international reserves to
fund modest and temporary budget balance
of payments deficits have implemented
counter cyclical monetary and fiscal
policies intended to prevent output from
falling too far below the globe
potential the resources for governments
to implement counter cyclical
macroeconomic policies or at least to
avoid having to implement procyclical
fiscal tightening have also been boosted
by the IMF World Bank
DB as I pointed out the long-term
implications for developments are
difficult to predict but in some senses
they are positive in that governments in
Africa have gained more confidence in
their own ability to manage their
economies even in the face of severe
external shocks especially because
macroeconomic management in Africa has
been relatively successful most
economies have avoided every session as
a consequence African policymakers are
likely to become more assertive in
future in terms of formulating their own
economic policies independently of the
IFS the global economic crisis has also
undermined confidence in efficacy of
Orthodox neoliberal economic forces
across a wide range of issues from
industrial policy to financial
liberalisation and food security as a
consequence it is likely that African
countries will adopt more heterodox
forces in the future with probably a
larger role for the state in allocating
resources in commercial sectors I think
this is the visible hundred was was
referred to under Malawi started a
program of giving fertilizers to to
farmers this was before before the
crisis to boost domestic maize
production a policy which is regarded as
being quite
Fred would therefore probably be
emulated elsewhere in Africa Ethiopia
and Rhonda are also leading the way in
using smart government interventions in
a wide range of areas intended to boost
economic growth and improve welfare now
what r or african actors and
institutions play in framing the
implementation of 8 despite all the
rhetoric about global partnership
between 88 donors and recipients and
about shared objectives we just
characterized global fora on eight
African governments still play only
imagine of all in shaping ADA policies
Africa has two smaller share of the
voting power at institutions which
actually have financial resources for
funding development meaning the World
Bank and IMF so the African countries
have very little influence of the
policies they have a larger voice in
United Nations but the UN agencies are
not major funders of paint other than
human for humanitarian purposes I think
I should stop there from okay thank you
very much
okay to get the discussion going out let
me ask a couple questions the first
question more of a partly a statement
but also reaction as you know there's
been a lot of criticism of aid from
people like easterly and a number of
other people and suggesting that aid
hasn't been very effective and there is
a somewhat of a literature that's
developed and trying to explain why it
might not have been effective so I want
to mention a couple of the arguments and
get your response to those arguments one
of them is that aid is very much like
natural resources and is subject to the
Dutch disease problems that is to say
there's something it's called the
natural resource curse countries with
large amounts of natural resources
haven't done very well on average and
there are three reasons for this one is
that the influx of foreign money leads
to appreciation of the currency is a
technical argument but when you are
currency appreciates it's very difficult
for employment job creation and so it
actually is counterproductive the second
concern is that natural resources are
very unstable and one of the concerns is
that foreign aid has been very unstable
one of the arguments deck South botero
gave a talk last week here said that the
reason that he was supporting a
financial transaction tax do support
foreign aid was it would be a steady
source of money for aid and there's a
whole initiative on on innovative means
of finance to give a shirred support to
avoid this variability and the third is
one that moved it to a little bit
add because it's not earned money you
get a lot of rank seeking behavior that
there's a lot of ranks they can behavior
associated with with natural resources
and some people claim that's also true
evade so these are three three arguments
that have been put forward for the Dutch
disease of natural resources and some
people claim there's a great deal of
similarity with aid in that and that's
one these are some of the reasons why
eight is ineffective there's one more i
want to put forward which blames the IMF
we try to get somebody from the IMF here
to to explain to defend their position
but that argument is one of the reasons
that a may be ineffective is that the
IMF tries to countervail the Dutch
disease problem and forces governments
to put the aid effectively into reserves
so the result of this is because they're
worried about the macroeconomic effect
it is on the effective eight in the
macro economic sense is undone by
central banks and and or basically by
IMF insisting on reserve accumulations
which mean that in fact there isn't more
money and there have been some studies
actually done by the IMF will show that
there's actually more than a little
truth in this allegation so just like to
get your your views on on that issue I
think there is some truth you are forced
fourth point and placing aid in
in results but I think it has to be put
within a context my view is that you
need a medium term expenditure framework
designed by the government and then
government's looks at different sources
of financing some of the sources would
be domestic and the other sources would
be eight and just like for natural
resources you need to have a medium
expenditure framework that is consistent
with certain desired growth levels if
you don't do it that way then you will
have an expenditure framework that is
influenced by aid and you go through the
cycles as it comes in increase
expenditures as it goes down you reduce
your expenditures what we did in Uganda
was to have such a medium expenditure
framework and donor resources came in to
finance the financing gap to the extent
that we got more than what we required
the excess was put into reserves that's
why I said that there is an element of
truth so whether you are dealing with
with natural resources or eight you must
have an expenditure framework the
government must design an expenditure
framework and then align resources to
financing that expenditure from one the
couple of things you know Joe is
alluding to the pretty extensive
literature not only on you know why has
a
not been effective but whether aid has
been effective and for those who are
interested in haven't seen it if you
google aren't arnd t and chin tarp t
AARP you will come up with an article
that like some of the people I've talked
to have said is the the latest one to be
beat all these articles eventually get
beat but this is the latest one and it
says in fact that you know eight has
been a lot more successful than people
have given credit for and you know
you've got this this problem econometric
and and and practical if the countries
that are doing well you give less aid to
and they graduate and the countries that
are doing badly and you really want to
help you give more aid to becomes very
practically comes very difficult to
figure out you know which way is the
causality going and so so I but anyway
take duty I just yeah mention there I
there there are some kana metric
techniques that some people use you may
want in common there was one study that
looked at it in the following way it
turned out that countries the
allegations the countries that voted
with the United States in the Security
Council and the UN got more aid so that
was a case where aid is correlated with
politics not with need and then they
looked at do those countries to get more
aid because the politics do better or
worse I can't remember what the answer
is but but the that there are these
techniques that try to look at that do
you have any view on those papers well i
mean first of all if anyone tries to say
to you that political factors did not
influence eighth allocations maybe
they'll sell you the Brooklyn Bridge
along with it but so what I you know
when you at the point is when you add up
the aid recedes you have to see how much
of a bias is there and I it it seems it
seems to me that econometricians are
never going to really resolve this kind
of a problem of whether taking account
of issues of me taking account of
political issues has an taking account
of the country's capacity to use money
well you know talk about performance
that sounds terrible but if you say
should you take account of what you
think the likely use of the money is
going to be well who would be you know
just imagine that you're it's a question
of giving money to different members of
your family or lending money you can say
jeez some of them really if I help them
out they're going to do very well with
that and others are not and so when you
get into these arguments about Dutch
disease and all that which certainly is
true i mean if you've got a big windfall
whether it's a door or minerals you're
going to have difficulty but the donors
recently in any event seem to have been
concentrating on both trying to provide
more aid for the countries that really
are helping themselves that have
demonstrated they're going to do it but
at the same time trying to find ways of
dealing with the issue that both Lewis
and I raised of my god the consequences
of abandoning the countries in need are
a pretty serious let me ask one more
question before opening it up and you
talked about the China which you listed
as a non-traditional donor actually I
think China has actually been in
involved in Africa for a very long time
although not to the extent that it has
been recently but the subject of Chinese
aid to Africa has gotten a lot of
attention United States like a couple
question I want to ask get both of your
views on one is that that China makes a
great deal of claim about
non-intervention in the internal affairs
of other countries and you mentioned
that that in some sense was a positive
thing because they were poor composing
less conditionality those who are
advocate conditionality looks a geeks
and negative things a lot of people in
the American Human Rights community are
very worried about that lack
conditionality the implications for
Sudan and for for other countries the
response that they say as well why why
is the West suddenly getting religion
when for 50 years you never worried
about these issues so I just like to get
your view on that the second one is
there there are a lot of allegations
that china is mainly they're for natural
resources but at the same time China has
been engaged in countries like Ethiopia
where there are very few natural
resources and just began to get your
view is to what extent is that is there
a disinterested and third is that while
they're there are economic interests
they were also political interest and
it's very clear at least as I see the of
China's increased influence in Africa
and the concern about us many Americans
is that we've been America has been very
absent in Africa particularly recently
accepting some very localized area like
AIDS medicines and is this a subject
that the US should be concerned about if
you were giving advice to Obama would
you say
should you give more aid and in what
form that's a multiple um that's my
question anything but will tell him
whatever you say so so it's serious I'll
start with the two issues about Donna's
I think as Paul said underlying the
giving of aid interests of the dollar I
think you can never run away from from
that I think whether you are dealing
with China or any of the other
traditional traditional donors that's
one the second one which is two very
debatable whether these conditionalities
have actually worked in Africa I think
what we had during the crisis was that
less going with less conditionalities
and you we saw that with most of the ifs
and development banks and there are many
people who now say that because we were
able to react fast with least conditions
we were able to avert a crisis so there
is the whole issue of whether we always
be increasing conditionalities or not
the fact of the matter yes China has
come in it has got its interests and
natural resources are some of its
interests and is coming in with this
policy of non-intervention that's the
way they are sold it my view is more of
a message to the African countries that
even this whole debate between
traditional and non-traditional donors
the message to the African countries is
that we may have made mistakes of the
post-independence period as we dealt
with
traditional donors if we are not careful
we might make mistakes in our
relationship with with China I think we
must have our own development programs
and negotiate with China to align
resources to our own development
programs otherwise they will come and
I'll say we need a road from A to B
which may be a road from here to a mine
look at the map of Africa look at the
railroads and the roads that were
constructed during the colonial times
they were constructed in a manner that
was intended to to exploit the natural
resources of Africa you look at that map
of Africa there is very little that
connects landlocked countries across
Africa most of these words words and
larry's to the sea China might come in
and just also construct other roads and
Larry lines and whatever to get minerals
and all out of Africa so it has to be
the African countries to come up with
their own development plans and talk to
Don us to align resources to those
development plans and I think the
example you bring out of Ethiopia
Ethiopia to me is one of those countries
that clearly has a vision of where it
wants to go and deals with Donna's given
that vision and does is very selective
between donors they know that china is
very good in this area and they want to
do with China in those areas and I think
has benefited a lot from its aid program
with with China and I mean the other
African countries should emulate that
otherwise we are likely to make the same
mistakes of having rods Larry's leading
to exploit
look I agree with what Alyssa said I'd
like to get on to other question I'll
just put a couple of things on let's say
add a couple of things on China you know
China is getting to be a very big
economic power clearly if you think
about it it's aid Africa is not that
dissimilar to we're talking before
Japan's aid to Africa and to Asia at an
early period now japan still has
commercial interest still has political
interest but japanese aid has changed an
awful lot maybe partly tie but it's less
tied there's a lot more support for
country programs coming from Japan and
you know China is is growing so rapidly
it's so big that I think if China is
treated with respect in the aid
community it's not going to drop its
interest in Natural Resources tomorrow
or even 15 years no but I think you can
see on their side some corresponding
changes in behavior and as you know as
Laura said that the African countries
need to assert themselves more as far as
the u.s. goes I think you've you've put
it about about right Joe cause you there
was an answer implicit in your question
strangely enough and there's there needs
to be less more support you know that is
not tied to very specific things
hiv/aids is a horrible problem it's
terrible but for the u.s. to put 15
billion dollars into that and almost and
very very little into health in general
that's not the right thing and in fact
President Obama has talked both about a
broader initiative on global health and
taking this money that was reserved for
just HIV HIV AIDS and using it more
generally and it ought to be for those
tree is a particularly that are doing
well much more general support for the
public expenditure program as Lewis said
of the countries themselves and one
other radical thing might be this
suggests to President Obama that there
may be something to learn from other
countries and we're talking before about
how diffidence really interesting
there's been a change in government and
if it and there are changes in aid
policy but from our point of view there
are tiny I mean there's a real
continuity and there is there a support
for overall country programs some
selective stuff in sectors so maybe the
idea that we don't have all the answers
would be another thing to say yeah those
you're going to know different is the
British aid agency let's open it up to
the audience do we have microphone
anybody know okay oh you either have to
talk with a loud voice or come there's a
microphone I don't see
hi thank you um my question is and I
don't really you know there was a lot
being said about states needing to have
greater capacity and greater say my
question is how do you think that
African states can leverage themselves
with donor agencies both China and you
know other large donor agencies in order
to have a greater say in a processes
yeah i'm going to gather two or three
questions at a time and then let you
answer them so can you just run hi I'm
also wondering about the role of a
couple other actors in development in
aid specifically I'm to give
international organizations such as ms
hustle full tiara the Soros Foundation
action against hunger and then the role
or if what you make of south-south
cooperation that's something that the UN
is pushing I know that's all there's a
question down here here is inside thank
you with everybody mentioning the role
of ND of China and India perhaps and
different agencies defeat and the UN the
World Bank the IMF how is it possible to
monitor all this kind of eight and if
what is the future of the age structure
as you see from 10 years from now is you
have all these agents competing with
each other and if money is to be put
into budgets and not to be given as in
projects in the format of projects and
programs it will be very hard to monitor
and I can't see how it can be done with
the systems that are are in place today
I let me start with the the last one and
then I'll move back to the capacity I
think from the African point of view we
have always had problems of dealing with
with donors for each project you'll find
several missions coming from the donor
country and in most cases each mission
wanting to see your most vital everybody
within within the hierarchy so during
the 90s we promoted more and worked with
the IFS to see that we had joint
programs where there was the donors
coming together to finance a budget
program or a medium expenditure
framework that is designed by by
government that was in a way reducing
the kappa i mean reducing on the
requirements on the government of on the
government to respond to different
donors but even then you would find some
individual donors wanting to walk
outside that program i think that's the
percent point of being accountable to
your parent you on say yes we do to this
school years we put up that hospital it
is a problem now with china and india
now coming on board chances are that in
the short run china may not join this
joint donor groups because of
differences in the type of
conditionalities they are setting and
definitely it will be a problem for for
for the african countries dealing with
different donor requirements now the
other point is on monitoring outcomes i
think the my view on that is you have to
use monitor it from the point of view of
the body
yes I put in these resources and this is
what I have been able to achieve now on
the the first question on the capacity
of African countries one thing that I
would like to bring out is the case of
Ethiopia and aunt Rhonda I think those
are two very clear cases where the
leadership I think has a vision of where
they want to go and they can say no to a
donor who is providing aid outside the
medium term expenditure framework
outside their priorities and I think
that's what we need to do in a number of
countries we must be if i can borrow the
word used by poor we have to be more
assertive and know what we want and go
into negotiations with donors and say
yes this is what we want we are not
going to put more money in health we are
going to put more money in education
although your priorities is education
and there and and health because that's
a mistake would be in the 90s where most
countries designed their development
programs putting a lot of emphasis on
health and education because the
resource that was available was for
health and an education and we all
ignore the infrastructure now we have
the infrastructure jobs and we are
trying to catch up well let me start
with the second question about MSF and
and my response that is thank you so
much for raising that civil system
ention civil society and then
foundations civil society has and should
have at the international level and at
the national level within Africa a more
and more important role and it okay
inside a personal example I've been
involved recently in an initiative about
a global strategy of nutrition but this
is a nutrition initiative without an
earmark funk and MSF and Helen Keller
International and bread for the world
and it's a most of the major NGOs
advocacy and operational I have been
involved with this along with UN
agencies along with the donors and I and
I think it moving in a sense to the
second question that is really going to
be the path what we are going to see in
the future if we can come back to the
term architecture here and now you know
do the foundations well Soros is very
big but wow just think of gates and
Buffett and what that's going to mean
and their efforts to get other
billionaires around to put up money so i
think the the table is going to get
bigger and more complex and that's where
i think transparency is is awfully
important and there is a major
initiative lead in fact by the british
bye-bye divot a international aid
transparency initiative it's not going
to get china and immediately but it's
making some progress and you know the
discussion of china china has made me
think of some
that the next high level forum on Aid
Effectiveness which is going to be next
year is going to be on curry in Korea
and it's going to be in Korea because
Korea is an aid donor and Korea is
really in a sense in the similar
position to China it's smaller but some
of the same tensions and yet Korea
recently did join the development
assistance committee but so I think once
again there's room for some kind of
middle ground if everyone is treated
with a certain amount of respect and if
at the same time we recommend well of
course there are political and
commercial interests and African
countries and others need to be aware of
that and respond in a massive way we
have time just for a couple more
questions are there yeah this is very
very interesting meat what I when I
don't quite here and I'm not sure it's
just I'm not that familiar with
economics and I'm not that familiar with
the nature of the aid issues um but I'm
interested that I'm not hearing a
certain kind of structural
considerations with respect to the
nature of I mean the use of the word
family was interesting for example if
and more anthropological than I'm
hearing in other you know from some of
the other speakers the notion of the
theory of the gift for example which is
that the gift always wants to be
returned to the giver it incurs
obligation it's required that there be a
circulation back to those who are giving
the gift and of course that comes in
many forms political forms and so forth
but what I'm interested in is actually
the specific structures in Western
culture say the united states such as
the philanthropic structure or the
various federal aid structures that
allow a kind of aid to go forward
into another continent and to find a
place there without a cent in a sense so
I mean I was interested in the rattan
you know the reaction to that has to be
another structure a philanthropic
structure or kind of civil structure
that would be able to organize the
acceptance of the money in a way that
wasn't just passive and you know and
sort of at the mercy of the gift and so
I really so I I'm not exactly hearing
I'm not hearing the economic version of
that so I just like you here for ya this
might be actually paraphrase some degree
but if these donor dollars are liberated
from their mark agendas and you let
local decisions being made as opposed to
the global agenda being executed then my
question is to what extent and not
addressing the NGOs and the privatized
you know the institutions that can
outskirt the federal but then the
question is to what extent are the
government's facilitators vs. obstacles
and what I'm saying is how come dollars
ensure that representatives or you know
officials are activated representing
representing the people the constituents
can you can this money somehow ensure
that connection because it's I don't
know other ways to bypass then give it
directly to people okay okay couple
questions down here on the side
I think this question is related and I
was just hoping that the gentleman from
the central Ugandan bank is that we I
was just hoping that you could maybe
illustrate for some of us who are non
economist the procedure by which aid
would be a factor in sort of planning a
medium expenditure framework for example
one of the challenges that was presented
today is capacity and I know that a lot
of African governments don't have the
capacity to collect taxes so if your
plan you if you're a preemie problem is
that you don't have a regular stream of
revenue coming in how do you go about
planning a medium expenditure framework
and then once you do how does that shape
the location of where oh where a can be
best utilized because I think sort of
imagining even be able to even being
able to begin to plan a medium
expenditure framework when you already
you know have a volatile stream of
income is a big challenge and I would
just like for you to walk through us you
know help us imagine the procedure by
which you would you would tackle there's
a question back there two questions
really one is the issues alluded to
which is capacity it's often the case
that a lot of Afghan government I'll
speak for instance for my country
Zimbabwe I've just spent the last four
months working for the wall bank and it
turns out that the central government's
capacity to actually do things to
implement even if they are given money
is very very limited compared to say
that of NGOs you find that you know NGOs
like UNICEF have more qualified staff
than say the government can use is that
can you speak to that in terms of what
because is in other African countries
and the impacts on how aid ends up being
either effective or not so effective the
second issues on the issue of the
African Diaspora is African countries
are kind of crumbling because of the
the issues that they're facing we're
seeing a huge migration of people
leaving their countries I can speak
again for my country which is
twenty-five percent of the population
has left the country mostly like
qualified professionals in the next SE
5-10 years I know for effect that now
most of the donors don't really know how
to deal with the issue of the Diaspora
do you see can you comment on that may
be a model of how that can the Diaspora
can be incorporated into making a more
effective last question way in the back
there loud and clear okay okay my
question is you brought up the issue
that African countries need to be more
assertive and I know in in some
countries there are military governments
or sometimes the government's or just or
Corrupter and there's just a lot of
different political issues so how can
with the current structure that are in
place in some of the actual african
countries like how do you see them being
more assertive is it going to be from a
policy standpoint or is it going to be
something that is is on the local level
and you can you ask where you can
incorporate any other comics money oh
thanks out having had a chance to have I
say before i'll try and stick to the
questions that have been raised the
question about sort of the cultural side
and what a gifts imply i think that's
really important and you know as the
amount of funding coming from
philanthropies in particular increases
and there aren't any rules again you
know after five decades or so
are better or for worse there are
agreements on rules of the game Paris
and Accra of cords between recipient
countries who haven't been assertive
enough but they have a lot more power
than they used to and the donors well
the philanthropies are kind of
unaccountable and they're going to be
huge and it seems to me that there needs
to be some way of not of an
accountability structure other than to
their own individual donor so that we
aren't just seeing this their own views
running running rampant as the the
amount gets bigger and I think that's
really an important issue that you've
raised now they're in several questions
about well can you trust those
governments and those are very important
questions if you go back to what Luis
started with he said you know countries
are different so there are some
countries that are clearly quite capable
and I hate to you know to say it but as
I said in my opening remarks some of the
capable countries indeed our military
the issue for millennium development
goals for poverty reduction rather than
for human rights and democracy and human
rights and democracy are extremely
important but the issue for poverty
reduction and MDGs is is there to what
extent is their objective development to
what extent are they driven to provide
services and in those countries that are
have shown that they're effectively
doing that then there's a real moral
dilemma there and if you really are
committed to helping reduce infant
mortality etc that you know it seems to
me that those are governments that have
shown that they can do things they ought
to be the second the second point is
they certainly ought to be pushed on
human rights and that's where
get back to this question of you know
conditionality well it's got to be frank
dialogue you're not going to have
conditionality saying you ought to stop
being a military government but they
shouldn't get to the point we're the US
or any other country doesn't raise these
important moral issues in the and they
have to be dealt with in a frank way now
having said that I've you know I said ok
so there's a bunch of capable countries
of those some of them we really have
issues about human rights etc there is
there is you know is Louis and I were
both talking about the fragile states
and there's a lot of them and frankly
it's a very big challenge because some
of them are fragile because they really
want desperately to do the right thing
but they don't have the capacity and you
can certainly work with those
governments directly but indeed there
are others were you the last thing you
want to do is turn over large amounts of
money directly to them and they're the
trick is to find ways to help provide
services in the short run but as Lewis
said also to strengthen the state in the
medium term to think about you know is
it just going to be a parachuted in
health program or is it going to be
something that can lead to something
that's sustainable Thanks on this issue
of trusts how can you trust at what
point do you trust so that you can use
the budget as an effective instrument
for purposes of
improving the welfare of the people it
can be a difficult call there are risks
that donors will have to take take my
own country in Uganda if one can visited
you gonna in 1986 we're all state
functionaries had been eroded in 86 your
recommendation would have been don't use
the budget go round the budget in terms
of offering services to the people but
some countries did actually take risks
and worked with government strengthen
the step and I think the results now i
wouldnt that you have a function instead
you have a civil service that is able to
draw up a medium term expenditure
framework so i can't say it is a science
you decide as to whether you deal with
this government or the other government
but you you have to take some risks to
is the issue of the fragile states i
think there will remain a very big
challenge fragile states will remain a
very big challenge to all of us and it
will always be a very difficult call as
to whether the budget is transparent
enough and effective as an instrument a
very very very difficult call I I was
sent to Zimbabwe last year in March
after they actually it was much after
the unity government came into power and
the question was how do we design
interventions by the African Development
Bank and I talked to different donors
we're on the ground and you could hear
skepticism by many of the donors I
recall going back and giving my report
where we took some risks and
no we'll have to deal with the
government and we started relationships
with the Ministry of Finance and you are
right Zimbabwe many of the professionals
left in the case of Zimbabwe the civil
service is now much weaker than it was
in the nineteen but if you totally avoid
government you use only NGOs to provide
the services then you have this week
government that you are not working with
I think we have to take some risks and
try to see that yes maybe in the initial
stages we may avoid government but we
know we are going to deal with it within
the medium term we might as well start
strengthening it so that it can be an
effective instrument so you are right
that the in some of these countries
especially in the week steps even
planning itself coming up with a
government plan can be very difficult in
fact you may be dealing in a situation
where there is no plan but that might
mean that you will have to work with
different ministries different players
so that you come up with a plan now one
of the other question was that what if
the government is not representative of
the views of the people you may find
that even the NGOs may not they may also
have an agenda so this is never an easy
easy question for input now the other
point was how do we involve the diaspora
in assisting these weak governments can
we find ways of tapping in some of the
skills in the Diaspora I think the
Diaspora have got a very big role to
play in their home governments we have
to find ways of attracting some of these
people back in their countries but they
will not become a substitute to a weak
government I don't think that that
should be the direction we should take I
know the UN has looked at various ways
of getting the best bra back but at
times they also created distortions you
find someone in a ministry receiving
maybe two thousand and Allah's and
depart the other people reporting to
this one in the video are receiving the
equivalent of ten dollars a month I mean
it doesn't work you can't have only one
person running a whole ministry so yeah
we have to find ways that I don't have
easy answers to all these very difficult
questions well thank you very much let
me just remind first want to thank both
lewis and paul from coming from section
distances this friday sask assassins
city and echo crises conference is part
of the echo Bram and it will be here in
wood auditorium from ten a.m. to six pm
so for those of you who felt this was
too short that this will make up for
those of you like a longer conference
next week on thursday october seven with
the 6pm as a follow-up to tonight's
panel we are sponsoring a screening of
our friends of the bank
in warren hall room 310 it's a really
interesting movie I courage you to go it
is the story of negotiations between
Uganda and the bank and IMF and it's a
documentary that was remarkably Frank I
think the bank regretted it so I really
do encourage you to see it it these
exclusives may have changed it so it's a
little while from them but at least is a
nice historical look of what things were
like and maybe like today and there will
be a whole series of programs on from
the committee global thought on Africa
which will be posted as they get
finalized so let me again thank you all
for coming thank you